utf-8 is perhaps the best hack um the
best single thing that's used that can
be written down on the back of a napkin
and that's how it was put together it
was the first draft of utf-8 was written
on the back of a napkin in a diner um
and it's just such an elegant hack that
solves so many problems that i dilute ly
love it
back in the 1960s we had teleprinters we
had simple devices that you type a key
and it sends some numbers and the same
letter comes out the other side but
there needs to be a standard so in the
mid-1960s America at least settled on
ASCII which is the American Standard
Code for information interchange and
it's a seven bit binary system so each
letter you type in gets converted into
seven binary numbers and sent over the
wire now that means you can have numbers
from 0 to 127 they so move the first 32
for control codes and less important
stuff for writing things like like go
down a line or backspace and then they
made the rest characters added some
numbers and punctuation marks we did a
really clever thing which is that they
made a 65 which in binary are firing 1 2
4 8 16 32 64 in binary 65 is 1 0 0 0 0 0
1 which means that B is 66 which means
you've got two in binary just here C 67
3 in binary so you can look at a 7 bit
binary character and just knock off the
first two digits and know what its
position in the alphabet is even
cleverer than that they started
lowercase 32 later which means that
lowercase a is 97 1 1 0 0 0 0 1 anything
that doesn't fit into that is probably a
space which conveniently will be all
zeros or some kind of punctuation mark
brilliant clever wonderful great way of
doing things and that became the
standard at least in the
english-speaking world
as for the rest of the world they view
them did version
of that but you start getting into other
alphabets into into language that don't
you really use alphabets at all they all
came up with their own encoding which is
fine and then along come computers and
over time things change we moved to
8-bit computers so we now have a whole
extra number at the start just to
confuse matters which means we can go to
256 and we can have twice as many
characters and of course everyone
settled on the same standard for this
because that would make perfect amount
none of them did all the Nordic
countries start putting Norwegian
characters and Finnish characters in
there um Japan just doesn't use a ski at
all Japan goes and creates its own
multibyte encoding with more letters and
more characters more binary numbers
going to inch individual character all
these things are massively incompatible
Japan actually has three or four
different encodings are all of which are
completely incompatible with each other
so you send a document from one
old-school Japanese computer to another
it will come out so garbled that there
is even a word in Japanese for garbled
characters which is I'm probably
mispronouncing this but it's moti barkis
a bit of a nightmare but it's it's not
bad because how often does does someone
in London have to send a document to a
completely incompatible an unknown
computer at another company in Japan in
those days it's rare you print it off
and you faxed it ah and then the the
world wide web hit and we have a problem
because suddenly documents being sent
from all around the world all the time
so a thing is set up called the Unicode
consortium um
I mean what I can only describe as a
miracle over the last couple of decades
they have hammered out a standard
Unicode now have a list of more than a
hundred thousand characters that covers
everything you could possibly want to
write in any language English alphabet
Cyrillic alphabet Arabic alphabet um
Japanese Chinese and Korean characters
what you have at the end is the Unicode
consortium assigning a hundred thousand
plus characters to a hundred thousand
numbers they have not chosen binary
digits they've not chosen what
should be represented as all the other
side is that that that Arabic character
there that is number 5700 something and
this this linguistic symbol here that's
ten thousand something I have to
simplify massively here because they're
about of course five or six incompatible
ways to do this but what the web has
more or less settled on is something
called utf-8 there are a couple of
problems with doing the obvious thing
which is saying okay we're going to a
hundred thousand that's going to need
what to be safe that's going to need
thirty two binary digits to encode it
they encoded the English alphabet in
exactly the same way as ASCII did a is
still sixty five so if you have just a
string of English text and you're
encoding it at 32 bits per character
you're gonna have about 27 or 26 yeah
26 27 zeros and then a few ones for
every single character that is
incredibly wasteful suddenly every
english-language text file takes four
times the space on disk so problem one
you have to get rid of all the zeros in
English text problem two
there are lots of old computer systems
that interpret eight zeros in a row and
null as this is the end of the string of
characters so if you ever send eight
zeros in a row they just stop listening
they assume that the string has ended
there and it gets cut off so you can't
have eight zeros in a row anywhere okay
problem number three it has to be
backwards compatible you have to be able
to take this Unicode text and chuck it
into something that only understands
basic ASCII and have it more or less
work for English text utf-8 solves all
these problems and it's just a wonderful
hack it starts by just taking a ski if
you have something under 128 but can
just be expressed as seven digits you
put down a zero and then you put the
same numbers that you would otherwise so
let's have that a again
there we go that's still a that's still
65 that's still utf-8 valid and that
still ASCII valid brilliant
okay now let's say we're going above
that now you need something that's going
to work more or less for us key or at
least not break things but still be
understood so what you do is you start
by writing down 1 1 0 this means this is
the start of a new character and this
character is going to be 2 bytes long
two ones two bytes a byte being 8
characters and you're saying this one
I'm going to start it with one zero
which means this is a continuation and
then all these blank spaces of which you
have five here and six here you fill in
the other numbers and then when you're
calculating it you just take off those
headers and it understands just these as
being whatever number that turns out to
be that's probably somewhere in this
hundreds that'll do you for the first
4096 what about above that all above
that you go one one one zero meaning
there are three bytes in this three ones
three bytes with two continuation bytes
so now you have one two three four ten
sixteen spaces you want to go above that
you can the specification goes all the
way to 1 1 1 1 1 1 0 X with this many
continuation bytes after it
it's a neat hack that you can explain on
the back of a napkin or a bit of paper
it's backwards compatible it avoids
waste at no point will it ever ever ever
send eight zeros in a row and really
really crucially the one that made this
win over every other system is that you
can move backwards and forwards really
easily you do not have to have an index
where the characters start if you are
halfway through a string and you want to
go back one character you just look for
the previous header and that's it and
that worked and as of a few years ago
utf-8 beat out ASCII and everything else
as for the first time the dominant
character encoding on the web we don't
have that Mogi barking that Japanese has
we have something that nearly works and
that is why it's the most beautiful hack
that I can think of those use around the
world every second
we'd like to thank audible.com for their
support of this computerphile video and
if you register with audible and go to
audible.com slash computerphile you can
download a free audiobook they've got a
huge range of books audible I'd like to
recommend the last man on the moon which
is by Eugene Cernan who is the 11th of
12 men to step on to the moon but he was
the last man to step off the moon so I'm
not sure whether or not he really is the
last man on the moon or not sort of
depends how you define it but his book
is really good and what I really like
about it is it's read by sunan himself
which i think is pretty cool again
thanks to audible go to audible.com
slash computerphile and get a free
audiobook an old system that has been
programmed well we'll take those nice
curly quotes Microsoft Word is put into
Unicode and it will look at that and say
that is three separate characters